[музыка]
так вот ребят Мы приехали снова в
очередной разборка левичем приехали в
очередную страну в Эмираты Но в этот раз
мы приехали побороть свой страх то есть
побороть страх перед высотой перед
прыжком
[музыка]
Всем привет мы находимся вовсе Sky Night
Dubai за такой классный
красивое место приятная комфортно но мы
готовимся к прыжкам
[музыка]
очень оживленно очень энергично все
классно все заряжены всем страшно Но
никто не боится
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Я очень доволен Я вообще вот я безумно
начинаю потому что 10 килограмм сбросила
ради этого прыжка Да и заканчивается
прыжком вообще довольны Я обязательно
ещё раз пять повторю вот просто форело
ты такого
у тебя нету
OK Google
[музыка]
Это круто
я реально я бы знал чего ожидать Я
получил массу удовольствия массы
ощущение на самом деле я ожидал страшнее
на самом деле Вообще классный шикарно с
первого момента прям как вывалился
самолёта вообще
[аплодисменты]
мы пришли на баги короче будем рвать
песок
[музыка]
красота
это супер
[музыка]
Добро пожаловать
контраст чувствуется сразу Мы живем в
отеле там супер Люкс сюда выезжаем Тут
прям Реальная жизнь дает как бы ощущение
полноты картины мира
древние индусы строили
семьи
чтобы оставить свою историю
[музыка]
семья где богаче могущество свои хотели
этим показать вот этот комплекс
называется
в Риме
ничем ничем не уступает
[музыка]
полетели в Индию Сегодня мы посетили
Я думаю еще будем переваривать
культуру другой страны Сегодня мы гуляем
по делу
тоже время много богатых красивых храмов
различных богов которые заставляют
задуматься поэтому все
очень нравится немножечко
[музыка]
а-а ходили в гости а потом поехали
на экскурсию по Дели Классно Мне все
очень сильно понравилось Я в Большом
восторге у меня были слегка заниженные
ожидания а результат произошел сам себя
поэтому мне все нравится настроение
прекрасное Я готов поспать еще два часа
чтобы через два часа проснуться и
поехать смотреть тачмакал
[музыка]
обалденно очень прекрасно классно
фантастически великолепно невероятно
превосходно бомба ракет
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Да сегодня мы с утра 6 утра поразимся на
ногах съездили так Махал посмотрели его
это самое большое получается сооружение
как памятник любви
очень впечатление конечно оставила
осталось я думаю на всю жизнь
[музыка]
микроэкскурсия по старому делу это такой
Явный контраст между ними и старым деле
идешь как хочешь Наш другендер сказал
что это для того чтобы полноту жизни
ощутить чтобы знаете как добро не может
без зла существовать что не поймёшь что
такое добро если не будет зла так и тут
а ты не поймёшь как может быть это
просто расширение диапазона чтобы
понимать вообще как может быть поэтому
теперь мы будем ещё больше ценить то что
у нас есть сейчас мы находимся в
ресторане
не знаю точно его наверное название но
оно находится в старом старой части
неудерии в Старом городе по телевизору
ты конечно Это вся культура
это есть что-то что человек должен один
раз в жизни почувствовать и увидеть
Очень хочется увидеть настоящую Индию
[музыка]
деревенскую
неприкрытую Как живут Настоящие
индийские семьи
Ну конечно пробуду слышал
буддийские религия монахи вот чуть-чуть
больше узнать
философия как же поэтому что будет как
сказал правильно менеджмента ожидания
сильно много не ждем все что увидимся
все будем восхищаться
[музыка]
порядочность это такие твои слова и
действия которые побуждают других людях
желание работать с тобой всё
Смысл порядочности в том что это твои
слова и действия которые в других людях
побуждает желание с тобой что-то сделать
[музыка]
поэтому
делайте так чтобы много людей хотели с
тобой работать и тогда у тебя будет
выбор Тогда ты можешь поднимать цену
И вот пожалуйста вот бизнес пошел тогда
ты можешь выбирать с кем работать с кем
не работать самое интересное если ты
порядочный и люди тебя так воспринимают
то к тебе очередь желающих с тобой
работать соответственно ты выбираешь с
кем еще работать соответственно
порядочным быть самый эффективный способ
достичь успеха Что такое проблема это
вовремя не принято решение она же не
бывает в один день до этой проблемы у
вас были какие-то симптомы сигнал один
вы не среагировали сигнал Второй вы не
среагировали сигнал еще меньше вы не
среагировали меньше не среагировали и
вот сначала она появляется как маленький
сигнал как знак Потом больше сигнал
Потом больше ты не реагируешь больше
больше больше она становится проблемой и
теперь ты не можешь не реагировать
потому что это проблема занимает все
твою энергию Все твое внимание
на эту проблему это природа проблемы
поэтому хороший руководитель всегда
говорят когда приходит компанию они
говорят я тот человек который хочет
слышать плохие новости первым
Почему когда когда сотрудники ему
приносит плохую новость первым не
бояться он начинает реагировать раньше
на проблему
а в решении проблем главное правило
такое что корневую причину проблемы
решить гораздо дешевле и быстрее чем
саму проблему поэтому Когда вы
столкнулись с проблемой Не пытайтесь
решить проблему
Задайте пять вопросов Почему почему Это
возникло у вас появится причина А почему
Это возникло появится 3 А почему Это
возникло появляется четвертое А почему
Это возникло появляется пятое пятое
иногда бывает 7 вот в этом промежутке
это Корневая причина Любой Ваш рост это
рост одного параметра вашей
эффективности
все потому что если растет ваша
эффективность вы Растете растут ваши
деньги растут ваши возможности и так
далее
если ваша эффективность не растет то все
падает все падает соответственно Любой
Ваш рост Это только одно рост вашей
эффективности Почему я Обучаю людей
только эффективность потому что
эффективность количество результатов
деленное на количество ресурсов которые
ты потратил ресурсы входит энергия
внимание время тоже
Ты должен потратить меньше ресурсов и
времени чтобы произвести больше
результатов
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
там такой знаешь от Будды прям исходит
такой запах прям сильный гудит
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
здесь вот этот который храм
открытыми глазами констатировать даже
говорят моргнул свою вот этот глаз
поэтому испытание у нее пришли очень
много в конце когда той стороне это была
как Джунгли место такой природный храм
ничего такого не было И вот где дерево
вот он разным под деревом потому что
жарко
сидели чтобы комфортно было то он сидел
вот под деревом и вот прямо вот там под
деревом он
просветление как просветление тут
написано так чтобы он когда-то
медитировал какая-то весела он Земля
трогал иногда показывает будто поза
одной руки и он трогает землю и вот
получается после этого буддизм Индии
распространялся здесь который храм
раньше храмов не было Вот то что вы
видите это храм это всё попозже есть
буддизм три части
[аплодисменты]
за это время
я именно старался выбирать
туда где еще сам не был а совсем
Казахстане не был просто словами не
передать я честно говоря
не буду
не жалею здесь очень много оказалось
позитивных добрых людей когда есть
позитив и доброта всё остальное само
собой складывается уже без проблем тут
не было этого ребята Я очень много раз
ехал Запад чтобы
там учиться
а здесь здесь я понял что это все про
содержание суть
тут не надо кем-то быть что он быть
счастливым и тут не надо было года
только 9 дней чтобы это все про себя
пропустить и ответить мне было дико
приятно общаться с единомышленниками
которые как я вчера уже говорил думают о
завтрашнем дне не обсуждают то что было
вчера позавчера то что происходит
сегодня думаю о будущем ребята Мне если
честно очень приятно наблюдать вот
картину когда мы приезжаем первый день
знакомимся и потом когда уезжаем Вот это
чувство перед отъездом Когда мы уже все
как семья общаемся как Близкие друзья Я
испытываю уже в какой-то энной раз
первый раз я в Узбекистане в двадцать
первом году испытал ехал я тогда
исключительно пообщаться с парламентом
познакомиться и я не ожидал что будет
такой формат вливание в семью то есть
вот как реально одна планета одна семья
вот Этот уникальный формат и очень круто
когда э у нас здесь абсолютно разные
возрастная категория разные сферы
бизнеса но мы все полностью на одном
уровне общаемся а всем вам реально желаю
по приезду сделать мир чуточку
поездка наша началась с
посещения такого прекрасного места как
Дубай мы ехали туда с целью прыгнуть с
парашютом кайфанул Хоть я до этого И
прыгал с парашюта но в Дубае невероятная
картинка хочется это сделать
самостоятельно без инструктора наверное
для этого нужна подготовка А вначале
было страшно я изучала все
случаи вообще как это происходит поняла
что в принципе прыжок в тандеме И ты
сама не управляешь парашютом что
довольно безопасно после Дубая мы
полетели в Индию сначала в деле сделали
здесь несколько экскурсий тоже
посмотрели много интересных мест храмы
конечно еще трафик тут я такого трафика
никогда
сам и проехал и понял что почему нет
потому что они реально очень
ездят и один другого очень чувствует по
сигналам в Индии мне нравится контрасты
мне нравится
что мы за один день видим роскошную
богатую жизнь и видим
бедную
несчастную в чем-то
антисанитарию и эти контрасты заставляют
тебя задуматься очень понравилось она
очень колоритная очень богатая история и
люди мне очень понравились то что они
веселые несмотря ни на что они такие
спокойные вежливые Индия конечно меня
поразила своим колоритом женщины
прекрасные ходят очень красиво ярких
Саре очень вежливый добрый народ яркий
Это какая-то еда со специями это добрые
люди Вот правда добрые люди
очень много людей перемещение от одного
города другой это не так просто я был в
восторге от величия тадж-махала потому
что то ощущение
вечности
монументальности и
Величие
внушает какую-то силу уверенность в том
что мир был до нас мир есть с нами мир
будет продолжать жить после нас Это
вообще другой уровень ты и едешь и
отдыхаешь но в тот же самый момент Ты
можешь пойти с человеком поговорить
я потом если это вечером была беседа то
я до двух до трех ночи не мог уснуть
переваривал ставил задачи всё это
оформлял сразу оцифровал и старался
максимально быстро
чувствую что вообще моя жизнь наверное
изменится после этого путешествия Потому
что те решения которые мне предложил
я их внедрю и жизнь будет другая по
отношению к многим вещам инсайты будут
приходить еще долго после поездки мозг
должен все
отфильтровать Но самое главное это
конечно же компания единомышленников
очень круто Мы пообщались компании
смогла накалевичем с ребятами все очень
открытые позитивные Это моя не первая
поездка поэтому я уже точно знал что
ожидать именно от Круга общения можно
самого высокого уровня все люди открытые
заряженные позитивные на самом деле
очень благодарен и думаю что как только
я все внедрю все что получил Когда
появится новый вопрос осознанно копить
вопросы буду приезжать на такие
путешествияну и с удовольствием смотреть
новую страну и получать крутой опыт
крутого предпринимателя
хочу чтобы во всём мире узнали
[музыка]